okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of q a about history of science
and technology
presumably our last one for 2021
i'm happy to try and address questions
about either
history that i've personally been
involved in or things that i might have
studied i see that we have
a number of questions as always saved up
from previous times
so let's see we have one here from
floppy
do i think that science and technology
progresses the way that thomas kuhn
suggested in the structure of scientific
revolutions i.e things like paradigms to
crisis to paradigm shifts and so on
you know i have to say first first point
is that i had a copy of thomas kuhn's
book for forever and ever probably 40
years or so
and i've looked at it but i can't say
that i've ever actually read it cover to
cover
so whatever i say
about
the structure of scientific revolutions
can't be taken to be textually what
thomas kuhn talked about nor can i
specifically comment on that i can
comment on kind of the the pop version
of uh a summary of what thomas kuhn had
to say
but let me describe the way that i see
sort of progression happening in in
science and technology and so on
the the typical pattern is
a field progresses a field that there's
a there's a moment at which there's
typically a methodological advance
and
it's
and that
uh
basically launches a lot of
possibilities in a field now there's
sort of a
there's
a different kinds of methodological
advances there are ones that are
essentially driven by for example
technology the invention of the
telescope the microscope the you know
gene sequencing a bunch of different
things like this
those lead to lots of new information uh
computer experimentation and mathematics
lot lots of new information being
generated
as a result of a methodological advance
and there's then a certain amount of
kind of low-hanging fruit to be picked
from that methodological advance and i
think what i tend to see is
that there are a sequence of these
things that happen in different fields
once one of these has happened there's
five to ten to maybe a little bit longer
years of kind of low-hanging fruit to be
picked
and after that low-hanging fruit has
been picked there's then the kind of
slow cruise phase where people are kind
of using that methodology gradually
tweaking things gradually expanding on
it and that can last 50 years 100 years
until there's another methodological
advance and suddenly lots of things
change in that field
i think that's
in in lots of fields i've seen that's
been a a characteristic kind of pattern
uh you see that i don't know machine
learning is a field that's that's
recently had sort of a well 2011 had a
sort of a big burst
of methodological advance
the field had sort of existed in some
form
since the 1950s or so but it had been
slowly progressing and then suddenly it
takes off
um
i think that uh
uh the the thing that i i'm thinking you
know thomas kuhn was more talking about
had to do with shifts of thinking shifts
of the paradigm with which one thinks
about things
now at some level those are also those
also relate to methodology but it's not
kinds of technological methodology of
doing a new kind of experiment or
something like this it tends to be a new
way of thinking about things and it
tends to be
something where there is in a sense
technology but it is abstract technology
it's things like mathematical technology
or model making technology these kinds
of things
and again that's something that one has
seen happen a bunch of times um once
seen it uh
uh
with um well i've been involved in in
some of these um i think that um
a uh
a typical example might be the the
moment in the 1600s
when kind of the idea of applying
mathematics to make fundamental models
of the world
came into existence first with galileo
then more seriously with newton 1687 and
so on this idea that you could use
mathematics not as just sort of an
extrapolation of what was happening in
the world and to calculate things that
sort of you already thought were in the
world but as an abstract way to define
new models of the world and to invent
things about laws of gravitation where
you could uh sort of solve for motion
and things using equations those kinds
of things the the write down equations
and have them represent the world was
kind of a a shift in the paradigm of how
to think about the world that had been
previously more let's reason about the
world and so on i mean i myself was
deeply involved in another such shift uh
starting in the 1980s um the idea of
using programs as sort of the raw
material for making models of things in
the world
and i think that that that idea has been
a
in some sense it's it's
it's i suppose it's a radical idea in
some ways to me it's always seemed like
rather an obvious idea um but
that idea has sort of taken about 40
years to kind of work its way through to
the point where sort of typical new
models for things are now made in terms
of programs rather than in terms of
equations
um i would say that that particular
paradigm shift has in some ways been a a
fairly quiet one in the sense there's
just been this sort of quiet
change from equation-based pro models to
to program based novels now you know i
have my my book new kind of science that
came out in 2002 was kind of a a a loud
description of this kind of approach of
using programs rather than equations as
ways to make models of things
and i would say that it was kind of
interesting for me to kind of live
through the actual on the ground moment
of impact paradigm shift type type thing
um i think one of the features of
paradigm shifts tends to be that the the
two things change the methods of
description that are used for things and
the things that one is trying to
describe the kinds of questions that one
is asking
and i remember talking to an older
mathematical physicist
uh when new kind of science first came
out
and uh he said you know i look at this
book and i i i all it has in it is
pictures and and programs
and you know i just don't understand any
of it
he'd spent his whole career
basically studying the mathematical
equations based approach
to to doing physics
and for him the kind of the the the the
methodology and description of a new
kind of science was utterly alien it was
something where
it's like that's a program i don't know
how to describe things in terms of
programs now it turns out that is the
sort of a key paradigm of the 21st
century is to use computation to
describe things but this person was
firmly sort of educated and and uh and
situated in the 20th century
and i think that the
um uh that's
that's one thing is the kind of the
question of what
uh of how you describe things what is
the
uh
what what are the kinds of raw material
that you use to
to make descriptions is it an equation
is it a a program is it
do you talk about things in terms of
i don't know
genetic sequences or do you talk about
them in terms of traits of this that and
the other what what is the sort of raw
material for describing things
another issue is what kinds of questions
are you trying to answer or ask
and that's something that when you sort
of change the paradigm you change the
questions that
that get askable
and and that people get interested in
asking
you know a classic example has to do
with uh fluid flow
and
it's
there was extensive study from the
equations of fluid flow the
navier-stokes equations invented i think
in the 1830s or so that are differential
equations that describe the flow fluids
and people have been interested in all
sorts of special cases of those
equations and when could you solve them
when could you not but you know when you
actually look at fluids in the wild one
of the features that they have is the
phenomenon of turbulence a fluid flows
rapidly it kind of curls up in all these
random patterns of flow
and you might have thought that if you
were interested in fluid flow that that
was kind of a front and center issue but
it wasn't there were people talked about
it people made comments about it they
had models a few models of it but really
turbulence was not a front and center
story in fluid mechanics what was the
front and center story was the cases
where you could solve the equations of
fluid flow where the methods that
existed at the time could actually make
progress the questions you could ask
mapped into the methods you could use
and that provided kind of the the study
of fluid dynamics
now with different methods ones let's
say based on programs rather than
equations you do get to say things about
fluid turbulence there's a lot more that
could be said but it's at least
something where it's sort of obvious
that you can start talking about it and
there are things to ask about it like
where does the randomness in it come
from which is not really a question that
was askable in a very serious way with
the approach based on mathematical
equations people had some approaches to
it based on sensory dependence on
initial conditions and chaos theory but
i think those rather missed the point in
these particular in this particular
issue
but so again when you have this kind of
new way of thinking about things there
are new kinds of questions that you can
ask and we've seen that in a in a major
way with the computational x fields as
they start to come into existence that
the kinds of questions that get to be
askable are just very different from the
ones that that were there before so i
think these are these are sort of the
three things that that i see as being
kind of
drivers of of major changes in in fields
uh one is the invention of new
methodologies at the level of technology
um uh or at the level of of uh
methods that can be used more abstract
methods can be used another is the kind
of descriptions that you can make
of
what's
of what you talk about and another is
the things that you
choose to talk about or consider
interesting so to speak now clearly
these three three things are connected
um there are clearly cases where
the the method of description is
critical
to um
to understanding what you can now ask or
to understanding what you should now
bother to go and measure those kinds of
things but i think those are the those
tend to be the drivers and the thing
that you tend to see
is once one of those things has once
those things exist
there is low hanging fruit to be picked
and that's a process that takes only a
comparatively limited time
you know
in in the bigger fields i think in the
whole computational x area maybe it'll
be 100 years that that's that's the
maybe 50 years that's that sort of
period of ramping but in more specific
fields i would say it's sort of five to
ten years is the typical time frame
and it's always a bit confusing because
those fields can go from just not
existing at all
to being things that exist they may not
even have a name at the beginning they
may be
and and it may be and they're certainly
not institutionalized at the beginning
it's only after that kind of ramp after
all the people kind of get into the
field they say it's all this low-hanging
fruit being picked let's get involved
there's all kinds of cool things to do
and you know one of the things that can
happen is that there are questions
where people said
oh that's just not a kind of question
that one can ask you might have thought
that a field like physics
would set its subject matter on the
basis of well it's talking about the
physical world but that really isn't
typically the case typically fields set
their subject matter on the basis of the
methods that those fields have developed
to be able to talk about things and
things that are outside that domain like
turbulence in the case of physics for
example tend to be like oh well that's
not really a physics kind of question
not because it doesn't come into the
domain of sort of studying physical
systems or something but because it
isn't it isn't approachable by the
methods that have been developed and
have become traditional in that field
so
interesting question i i think that um
uh the
the thing
well
you know i i've now lived through
a few of these paradigm shifts it's very
interesting uh it's very interesting to
see
kind of the response of people
because they've typically been
in in i mean my favorite cases is when
there isn't a field there at all and
when you're basically building something
like my book a new kind of science its
main thrust is to build something where
there just wasn't anything there before
the study of simple programs the study
of the computational universe those
kinds of things the applications to
different fields yes those fields were
there before and that's a place where
you kind of engage with people saying oh
my gosh this is a new paradigm that's
terribly shocking but the actual idea of
a new kind of science and exploring into
an area which just hasn't been explored
before
is something that uh uh well
for me is is is sort of my favorite case
but
it's um it's something where well for
example right now
uh i we've just sort of hit what i think
is kind of the the fourth major
um methodology paradigm for modeling
things
that has been something that's emerged
from our physics project and that's
really pretty extremely exciting
and i think is going to be incredibly
fertile over the next few years
and it's going to be interesting to see
how that kind of paradigm uh
gets under steam so to speak gets gets
uh gets into motion
i mean just to explain what that's about
i see there as being having been about
this is sort of the fourth of the major
modeling
methods of modeling things in the world
i think the first kind of approach in
antiquity it's kind of the structural
approach where you just sort of say what
are things made of you know is are
things made of atoms are things made of
epicycles and so on the second major
approach from the 1600s
is let's talk about equations for
describing things
and one feature of these approaches is
one can sort of characterize them by
thinking about how they treat the the
sort of the progression of a system the
the the
the notion of time in the structural
approach there isn't really much
discussion of time it's just what's
there in the system how is the system
built
in the mathematical equations approach
time can be a variable you just get to
kind of pick its value however you want
the third major paradigm for modeling as
i see it is the kind of computational
paradigm which i was involved in
initiating in the in the 1980s um i mean
it had precursors as everything always
does but i think the the sort of the the
big push
really really began in the 1980s
and um
the idea there is instead of having a
mathematical equation that describes a
system i mentioned you have a program to
describe it and there the notion of time
is a bit different because it's like
you've got this program you start it
running you go step by step by step and
that progression of the program is the
progress of time and you don't get to
jump ahead there's the this phenomenon
of computational irreducibility that
basically says to know what the system
is going to do sometime in the future
you pretty much have to follow each step
and see what's going to happen
so the sort of fourth paradigm which is
a new thing that's that's come out of
our physics project
thinks about
time not as this sort of single thread
of activity but as something which has
many branches and mergers and so on it's
something where you're dealing with
systems as we think the universe is
where there are many possible updates
that can happen
for example in different places in
physical space
at and they can be thought of as
happening simultaneously there's a sort
of it's it's a it's a flexible
definition of time so to speak something
which relativity had started to bring in
100 years ago but the notion is that
instead of there being a single thread
of time there's this kind of uh there's
this whole multi-way graph this whole
network of possible uh histories for for
things
and then the issue is well as an
observer of what's going on it's like
how can you tell what actually happened
well you are often for example in the
case of physics an observer who's
actually embedded within the system and
so when the system is branching and
merging so are you branching and merging
and it then becomes a whole issue of
what kinds of things can an observer
notice
about a system that's doing all this
branching and merging and so on
different histories and such like
and that sort of requires one to have a
more realistic view of the observer but
it turns out that it has a very great
uh consequence which is as soon as you
have an observer who's sort of like us
in certain ways has certain kinds of
bounded computational capabilities has
the belief that there's a single thread
of time even though in some sense from
the outside you can see the there's all
this branching emerging but an observer
like us
has the belief the assumption they they
sort of
think about the world in terms of there
being a single thread of experience as
soon as you have that and as soon as
that's the characteristic of the
observer it forces certain features to
be observed in that whole sort of
multi-computational as i call it process
of branching and merging and so on and
it turns out those features in the case
of physics
correspond very directly to things that
we see in detail about laws of physics
about general relativity and quantum
mechanics and so on and what's turning
out to be the case is that they're just
a whole bunch of other fields where this
kind of multi-computational idea can be
very directly applied they're fields
where to me it feels like those fields
have been stuck
sometimes for
50 years 150 years different amounts of
time they've been stuck because there
isn't a description a framework for
describing things in those fields that's
allowed one to really
make progress and so on and so i think
the exciting thing is that with this
kind of multi-computational paradigm
we're seeing the possibility to actually
make progress in a bunch of these fields
whether that's molecular biology
uh ideas about chemistry distributed
computing linguistics economics a whole
bunch of different fields uh
neuroscience where i think that that
there are sort of fundamental questions
foundational questions that have that
have been
usually ignored in those fields for
years because usually what happens in a
field is
at
when the field is is started
foundational questions are very much uh
front and center but after the field
develops particular methodology
particularly institutional structure and
so on the foundational questions usually
get long buried and those foundational
questions people say oh that's just too
hard or they say oh that must have been
answered a long time ago even though i
don't really know what the answer is
um and so it's it's uh so sometimes
those foundational questions get kind of
hidden or the field just describes
itself around defines itself away from
those foundational questions so that
they never have to be addressed
and in any case i think the sort of
fourth paradigm for modeling has the
very wonderful exciting possibility that
we'll actually be able to make progress
on a bunch of these different uh
uh
foundational questions in these
different fields and by the way what's
going to happen if that happens is
classic paradigm shift type behavior
in these different fields people will
say well i've been doing this field for
ages we describe things using equations
in this field we describe things using
various kinds of descriptive things that
don't involve equations um and so on and
then there's this new methodology and
the new methodology will be hard for
people who have been in those fields for
years to understand because it's built
on a tower of kind of abstract ideas
that came out of computation and physics
and a little bit of mathematics and so
on and it's it's pretty alien um and i
think that but
it's sort of interesting when that
happens because what typically happens
is that there's some small group of
people that for whatever reason either
are receptive to learning something new
or they already knew some things that
were relevant and they're interested in
that field and so they become this sort
of this this sort of
a small force that kind of injects
itself into an existing field as i say
it's a little different when one's going
out into sort of into the vacuum where
once we're once building a field where
there just wasn't anything there before
which is what's happening with kind of
the ruliology field that we're uh that
is kind of the thing that comes out new
kind of science this field of just
studying simple programs systems based
on rules and seeing what they do that's
something where there really wasn't much
there before i mean in the last 40 years
people have developed things
particularly i think
perhaps inspired by things that i was
doing in the 1980s and so there is a
rather fragmented
field of
some interesting contributions but it's
still rather fragmented hopefully we're
going to be able to define a little bit
more uh explicitly that field moving
forward but in any case that's a case
where it's sort of expanding into vacuum
in these other cases where you're
introducing a new methodology into an
existing perhaps several
hundred-year-old field
it's a it's a different story and there
you end up with a situation where
there's usually a small group of people
that know that new methodology and are
delivering sometimes they deliver
magical results
that
people who are in the field already say
oh my gosh we've been wondering about
that for ages you just delivered a
magical result that's one case the other
case is the new methodology comes in and
answers different questions from the
questions people have been asking before
and people who are in the field now will
say well that's nice but it's not really
part of our field it's really something
a separate kind of thing it's a
different kind of thing and sometimes
that's a better thing because sometimes
when it depends on the way in which the
magic results are introduced into a
field whether people just say oh that's
wonderful that's great whether they say
we hate it you know you're you're
overturning our field we've been happily
working in this field for years and we
don't uh uh you know we don't need all
this new outside stuff
um you know there must be something
wrong with this magic because it's so
alien
um and uh it'll be interesting to see
how that plays out in this kind of
fourth paradigm approach to modelling
and so on i'll be interested to see that
i i think one of the things that one has
to be aware of if one's actually at the
front lines of kind of the paradigm
shifty business
is
things things can get very weird i mean
in in
the
the way that um
people who've been doing something for a
long time kind of the reaction is often
quite to me quite unpredictable i mean
i've seen cases
where
fields have been in rather poor shape
and
you know i've been fortunate enough to
be involved in in bringing kind of a a
new injection of life into the field and
the people in the field are like hey
this is great
you know we've we're this is bringing
some new life to things that we care
about and we're interested in and
giving the field sort of a good
reputation and that's all good that's
case one case two can be
oh my gosh we don't want you you're an
outsider this is alien the methods
you're bringing in we don't understand
we hate it
uh you know pitchforks come out and it's
like let's try and run this person off
the reservation so to speak
um and let's try and hope that these
ideas kind of don't emerge in the course
of our careers so to speak
and
that
you know
my own feeling in those cases is
well
let that field go on its way
and try and break off another separate
field i mean in a sense is what happened
way back before my time
in mathematics versus computer science
there was a time in the maybe 1940s
1950s where sort of computer science
could have been part of mathematics
but people in mathematics didn't want it
i mean i remember once when i was at the
institute for advanced study in the uh
what was it early 1980s
um
there were people who had been working
at the institute with john von neumann
back in the 1950s building the uh the
computer that was built in the institute
and some of those people had had then
sort of scattered to different parts of
the world but they'd come back to the
institute for some kind of event talking
about uh kind of the history of
computers and so on and it was
interesting to see some of the
mathematicians who were at the institute
then and had in fact been at the
institute in the 1950s who would
absolutely i would say uh been been
horrified by this idea that at the
institute where
there was you know it was a place of
pure thought and so on there was this
nasty kind of oil i don't know if it
really had oil actually i remember
somebody saying the word oily about that
computer but i'm not sure it really had
much oil in it but anyway nasty electro
electrical device that filled the whole
building and so on that was
just a very alien kind of thing
and i think there had been an
opportunity at that time
for mathematics to sort of embrace
this notion of computation and theory of
computation and so on but it didn't it
pretty much spattered out and that's how
we came to have the field of computer
science theoretical computer science at
least
i've seen sort of the same thing happen
with a still not really fully under
under steam kind of um
field which is experimental mathematics
you know most of the methodology of
mathematics is you
uh as a pure mathematician for example
you are sort of imagining things and
you're trying to write down theorems and
you're trying to uh make proofs of those
theorems a tiny minority will use things
like proof assistance to sort of do that
in a more formal way i'm not even sure
that that's necessarily the right thing
in terms of you know it's kind of like
let the robot paint your painting kind
of thing rather than paint your painting
as an artist um but be that as it may
the um the idea mathematics progresses
by sort of imagining the next theorem
and then sort of making a bridge to it
and so on that is the typical way that
pure mathematics progresses
now there's a completely different thing
you can do which is you can just do
computer experiments you can try and
discover things that you never thought
were there just like you do in natural
science for example and you just sort of
make prongs out into this sort of meta
mathematical universe
of of things which you can explore but
which you hadn't even thought of before
and i've done a whole bunch of this
and in fact there are certainly examples
going back in history even hundreds of
years
where people were doing this as ways to
discover things gauss
riemann people like this all did various
kinds of experimental mathematics
uh ramanujan but it's a big one for this
the the thing is that that allows you to
kind of
make these prongs out into discoveries
that were not what you got to by kind of
bridging from one theorem to the next
now
there are a couple of things that can
happen with that one is those prongs
that you that you that you build out
you may end up in a place in sort of
meta mathematical space
that nobody cares about it's like well
this is a thing but there isn't enough
of a kind of cognitive bridge from what
people have already studied in
mathematics to get to that point to the
point where people say oh yes this is
something uh that um uh
that mathematics um
is uh you know that is that is the right
kind of subject matter for mathematics
um that's that's one thing um the uh
the thing that um
uh you could end up with um
well i would say that that's you kind of
this this prong that's not part of
mathematics
uh you can also end up with a situation
where
where you're
you're kind of i guess that's the main
that's the main thing that ends up
happening you end up also with a
situation where part of the story of
explaining mathematics is describing the
proofs of things and sort of having a
certain richness to the kind of
explanatory structure of a proof but
when my computer just found it
and yes i can formally see the proof
or i can formally see how the computer
got to that point
this is something very non-human this is
something again that is that doesn't
feel like it's it's part of the corpus
of ideas that um uh is encompassed in
sort of the traditional mathematics
but there's a lot that can i think be
discovered about the subject matter of
mathematics it's like the example of
turbulence in physics you can't get to
it by the methods that have been
traditional in physics but it is still
something which is should be in a sense
part of the global subject matter of
physics and so it is with experimental
mathematics there are plenty of things
you can get to with experimental
mathematics but where you can't really
reach that with the traditional
methodology and so that that's sort of a
an example of a kind of a paradigm shift
case in mathematics
which has so far been rather incomplete
i mean there are plenty of people myself
included who have delivered some sort of
perhaps magic seeming results
that can be thought of as mathematical
ones that simply come from experimental
mathematics
i think ramanujan was particularly big
on delivering sort of magic seeming
results
uh that came from sort of doing
experiments and having intuition about
them
well let's see
that was a long
explanation
let me see
more questions here
um
um
oh gosh so many things here
well
uh
all right let's do one
no okay this there's another
science question here's from ic
is science always based on finding
patterns in nature
you know i think the story of science is
a story of trying to
get to the point where we humans can
wrap our brains around what's going on
somewhere
and what does that mean in some sense
that means we have to find patterns
because lots is going on but we want to
find some sort of brain
reachable narrative for what's going on
if we say well there's
a trillion trillion trillion atoms
bouncing around in this box
and they're all doing complicated things
and let me tell you and it's going to
take me
you know a million years to describe how
each atom behaves that's not a human
reachable narrative for what's going on
so in doing science what we're
interested in is what's the human level
narrative where we can just kind of say
in a sort of a human level in in human
language or computational language or
whatever we can say
this is sort of what's going on in the
system so in a sense it's this it's a
sort of compression from what's actually
going on out there in the system to the
way that we explain what's going on that
seems to be the essence of what science
is about
and
so
if you say is it about sort of finding
patterns in nature
well first point is it's about finding a
narrative for what's going on in nature
or what's going on i wouldn't
necessarily in nature say in nature
because there's plenty of things that
are
in a sense
potentially accessible with with
science-like methods for example in
areas like mathematics and experimental
mathematics and so on areas like
linguistics and so on where it isn't
really something that is so much about
nature it is an abstract world out there
ruliology is another good example it's
kind of an abstract world out there
that we're exploring but we're trying to
explore it using the meta method of
science which is basically can we turn
all the things that are going on into
something which is accessible as a kind
of human level narrative and i think
that's uh that's kind of the notion now
uh interesting question whether
whether there is science that isn't sort
of human level narrative
i think machine learning is a place
where that is
sort of part of the story you know you
can say well i've got all these things
and i can make this machine learning
model of all these things and i can
pretty accurately predict what's going
to happen in different cases but i can't
really look inside the black box i can't
really get a human level narrative for
what's happening in that machine
learning system
so is that science the way we normally
think about science interesting question
is it useful for sure it can be useful
absolutely the technology that you can
build around oh let's use machine
learning to figure out what's the uh
you know what's going to happen to this
particular system in this particular
case and you know should we
change this
you know engineering thing based on that
in this case et cetera et cetera that's
all
absolutely useful and fair game for the
technological application of quote
science
whether the thing underneath that's just
a black box is something that we would
consider to be science in the sense that
we've meant science for the past couple
of millennia um is not clear um and i
think that's uh uh that's sort of a case
where where it's not so much i mean in a
sense the neural net works by quotes
finding patterns but it finds patterns
which are not related to a kind of human
narrative about these things
let's see there's a question from aaron
here why did networks computing grow
relatively slowly between the 1960s
arpanet and the 1989's http
was it a lack of imagining the
internet's potential or technical
barriers like packet switching and and
so on
that's an interesting question i mean so
i started using
uh the internet or the opennet
in 1975
or 1976
and um
the
i think
and how did i use it well i used it
through
kind of facilities at a university that
were part of government grants and it
was it was in a sense a very government
science kind of thing
and maybe part of the story was that in
the 1960s in particular in a country
like the us and probably other countries
as well
government science was the big science
and you know from the apollo project to
other kinds of things to to all the
things that were done with particle
physics and all these other places kind
of the government was the big place that
sort of science advances happened still
still the case that lots of the funding
for basic science that's where most of
it comes from but but i i would say that
my impression is that kind of the
government loomed larger in the progress
of science than perhaps than it does
uh perhaps today but but perhaps that so
so you know you only had access
to and these these things like the
arpanet and so on they were created
originally for very definitely
government purposes originally military
purposes um and then to sort of uh aid
in research that was sort of kind of
orbiting around those kinds of military
and other applicant government
applications so i think part of the
point was that the the typical access
that uh people had to that came through
sort of government-ish things
and so among scientists for example
there was a increasing amount of access
that
came through those channels now i i can
say
you know when i started using the
arpanet there were
i think there were 512 nodes on the
arpanet they all had numbers
my favorite was 236 which was a computer
at mit that i used to use from england
through some uh
bizarre connections
somewhere in i think scandinavia that
was some
military satellitey type connection
um that uh had been plugged into the
uh sort of science research arpanet type
thing
and you know you could literally go down
you could type at o and then each number
and and you'd get all kinds of weird you
know
uh i don't think you quite got a welcome
to norad screen but um
you would get you you can see all of the
different uh computers that were
connected to the arpanet at that time
but
that was definitely a uh an in-crowd now
the question is what would you do with
these computers okay so let's say you
reach one of these computers what do you
do with it
well you know i used a bunch of
this computer at mit that was the mit
project mac the multiple access computer
it was intended as a time sharing
computer that would run programs that
different people could use that was a
rare case
i mean uh in those days most computing
that um was was done
uh you know batch jobs were very common
where you would sort of submit your
cards or by that time virtual cards
sometimes to a computer and it would
then run them and uh and give you the
results back something which sort of
disappeared a lot during the personal
computer and workstation phase although
it's back now with with various kinds of
cloud computing and so on that you can
again run batch jobs i have a few big
batch jobs running right now actually
looking at something um where it feels
just like when i used to submit card
decks through a wooden pigeon hole so to
speak to get them run on a mainframe
computer
um but uh
i think i think what um
uh
so
the question was what would you do with
the computers that you accessed and how
did you get access to them
now the things that started happening
um
there was bitnet which was an ibm
sponsored thing as i recall that was a
network created for universities i i
that was
something i i don't know
i don't think i ever directly made use
of it
and then
there started to be the idea of dial-up
uh services of things like compuserve
these sort of dial-up systems where you
could get access to certain information
and so on and um you know that was
probably limited by the fact that to
connect your computer
to
the network
you would be you know dialing up on the
phone you would have an acoustic coupled
modem usually where you pick up your
physical phone you know a phone with
with a
a a uh um
you know a speaker and a microphone in
that in that big you know piece of
plastic and so on that's an actual phone
not a not a modern cell phone smartphone
type thing and you would take that
actual thing and stick it in this kind
of rubber uh container that would listen
for the tones that were being produced
there and allow you to communicate that
way and
it was not something where people
usually
thought of it as being something that
you continually did now i have to say
from the time i first moved to the u.s
in in 1978 um i was sort of amazed at
the idea that in the u.s local phone
calls were free that wasn't true in
england where i had grown up
and so what i did was i got my computer
uh my terminal for a computer at home
and i had a modem and i dialed up the
phone and i just connected the acoustic
coupler and i just left it connected
because after all
local phone calls were free and um
the
uh and i will say that that i was very
impressed by the phone system because it
would last for months there wouldn't be
a single glitch on the line it would be
a perfectly clear connection and my
computer my terminal was continually
connected to to to the computer that i
was dialed up to i have to say in a
somebody was asking questions about dick
feynman here uh dick fireman's longtime
assistant a woman named helen tuck
um i i knew her quite well and i once
mentioned her that i did this thing with
my with my computer at home or my
terminal computer terminal at home and
it turned out before she had worked for
dick feynman and mary gilman and the
theoretical physics department at
caltech she had worked for the phone
company for many years
and she was telling me you shouldn't do
that that's going to send a trouble
signal to the you know to the main
office if you just leave a phone
connected for months at a time that's
you're being horrible to the phone
network to do that
anyway just a small footnote to to
history there but
i think
then another thing that happened was
email
and email
was
originally i think the the earliest well
let's see i first used email in 1976
um as
part of
uh this
mitmc computer and i think also i used
it on the rutherford labs computer
system although not seriously
and um it was something where on a
particular computer people could send
you messages on that particular computer
um i was for many years
uh traumatized by the fact that i had
really wanted
the um the login sw
on that computer that i
was using back in 1976 but another
person had sw so i became s wolff and
that was my login for many many many
years
um
but uh in any case the um
the thing that uh that was that was
emailed directly on that single computer
system not something where you were
exchanging it with other computers the
thing that started happening was this
thing called ucp part of unix
which was a uh i guess that stands for
unix to unix copy and the idea was that
one computer would call up on the phone
another computer remember that unix had
been developed by labs which was the
research operation of the phone company
and so the idea that the that unix would
start making phone calls was thought to
be a good thing because it's like let's
use the phone system more and have
people you know pay more phone bills and
things like this but so uucp was this
kind of network where you would have an
email address that would be
one computer xclam another computer xlam
another computer it was a series of sort
of a routing for how to get from here to
there which would allow you to to send
mail to
to people through a sequence of
computers through phone calls and so on
and that became a thing
well let's see that was a thing
uh in the 1980s that was people used to
have email addresses that were bitnet
addresses and uucp addresses and things
like that but most people didn't really
use email at that time
um i would say that
that was something that sort of helped
stimulate what when
when um
modern smtp email came into existence
when was that
uh well let's see i i guess people
started using email fairly routinely
by
i would say
86 87 88 that was times when
when it started to be the case that
there were routinely
i'm trying to remember when people
started having emails on their business
cards um
that was probably not routinely the case
until until 1990-ish time frame
and
that and there were these various
services
uh where you could go pick up your email
from this particular place whether it
was compuserve or the well or a bunch of
other kinds of online services
and i i think i mean i have to say i
didn't use those really at all i used
those at most as sort of destinations
for communicating with other people um
but uh
let's see the question was why um
yeah why network computing grew slowly
you know i think
that
the idea
that you would
go to a computer remote computer to get
for example information was something
that came fairly slowly i mean there
were there were precursors of it
where for example i used to use in the
1970s a service called dialogue which
was a
a reference searching service that was
an aggregation
of a large number of databases that have
been used by librarians
and there were hundreds of these
databases things like uh but many of
them most of them probably still exist
things like the science citation index
and in spec and so on
and dialogue was something you would
dial up
you would uh
then uh you know you go and you do a
search and there were slightly obscure
you know such syntax that you would use
uh very much like a a search engine
actually except that it had much more
explicit syntax and you would say you
know how many how many items do you get
some number of abstracts for papers or
whatever you know print this set of
abstracts show them in more detail
whatever else the notion of things like
hyperlinks wasn't there yet
um
the uh but in any case with with
dialogue that would be a thing where you
would dial up to a specific place
specific number to get um to connect to
these databases and get the information
one wanted um and that's something and
then at the end it would give you a very
common thing at the end it would give
you this is how many dollars you spent
on this particular transaction
i would say that in terms of
generally connecting to
the the internet
it was um or the opennet
uh
it was
kind of um
well let's see
yeah there were
a lot of it for individual users was
acoustic couplers through the phone
system
through for institutions there were sort
of uh
direct
networked kinds of ways to to reach the
um the arpanet and so on
but um but again the arpanet was
something that was really used by people
in the kind of the orbit of government
kinds of things not the general public
um
and i think you know i remember
in
even in the in the late 1980s
that there had been a variety of
services that had come into existence
for just sort of collecting data from
remote computers there was gopher there
was wastes
and
both of them were just not that exciting
they were
text-based they were
um
they were
you know they were innovations but they
weren't things that were directly useful
to to somebody like me i mean i i used
email but i didn't use things like
gopher and so on and then the web came
into existence and i think one of the
key innovations of the web
was the fact that you could have gif
images and so on gifs have been
developed by compuserve
as a way to allow people to exchange
images um on uh
through
bulletin boards and things like that um
but
that was um
those were important innovations the
idea of hyperlinks was an important one
that i don't think existed in in gopher
and wastes and things like that it was
an idea that was an idea that had been
much championed by ted nelson
uh who had this very ambitious project
xanadu that he still talks about today
that was kind of a very
much more
kind of uh sort of the idea of this this
big network and but i think more of an
idea of of attribution of um
a value
rather than just oh you can follow that
link uh something that never developed
on the web was the idea of sort of micro
payments for oh follow that link and
they'll get a bill at the end of of
going and doing this web browsing the
web ended up getting defined as
something where that didn't happen um
which i think was sort of a
in some ways a quirk of history and it
was different from what was true on copy
server dialogue or any of these other
kinds of systems that involved you dial
up to some place to get access to online
kinds of resources
um
this is a this is a long rambling answer
and i'm i'm i'm sort of trying to
explain
different aspects of this because i'm
not sure i completely know
but it's certainly the case that things
took off uh dramatically
by the early 90s i mean i remember being
at um
uh
as i was at the world economic forum
event in probably in 1993
and there were all kinds of people there
with all kinds of policy people and so
on and i remember saying the web is
something you should take seriously and
people are like oh really oh that's
interesting okay you know write down
this web thing so that was something
that wasn't hadn't quite happened at
that time at least in the in sort of the
global policy world although it was
increasingly something that was known
to kind of the techie world i mean i
would say that the the other thing that
i really noticed with great amusement
actually was the time when http colon
slash whatever started getting painted
on the side of trucks as kind of a a
this is this is where you go to get
information about this service or
whatever and it was kind of a it was
kind of a
a remarkable thing when when one started
seeing that happening and when it became
kind of the the story of of uh a
forward-looking company was one that had
a website
um
and uh it was kind of like um these
different
places where different areas where
people would get websites and
and it was like when people got cell
phones i think like academics were
perhaps the last group that i noticed
getting cell phones sort of everybody
else you know the kids had gotten cell
phones long before the uh the academics
got cell phones and so on but in any
case
you know that was a a thing that i think
that transition must have happened i
remember you know when i first started
seeing you know trucks that had https
painted on them it was kind of a notable
thing and i think it's sort of
interesting that the the very obscurity
of http colon slash slash www dot
whatever that very obscure almost drivic
incantation i think was in some ways
helpful in kind of making the point kind
of this is a geeky techie leading edge
thing and that was sort of one might
have thought at the beginning when i
first saw that i was like that's an
incredibly bad design i mean you don't
want people to have to type that
sequence of what is it you know
11 letters or something at the beginning
of everything they type what a goofy
idea why do we need this you know the
default should be to not have to type
that and if you're trying to get to ftp
or some other service you can type that
but don't make the default be this this
long complicated thing but perhaps i was
wrong and perhaps the very fact that
there was that kind of druidic
incantation that was needed was
something that kind of helped the
theming of kind of the web is the
leading edge the kind of the techie
geeky thing
and perhaps that same thing is to some
extent been involved in cryptocurrencies
and and blockchain and so on that
there's a certain degree of kind of uh
kind of
unavoidable kind of geekiness to the
whole thing that sort of helps brand and
and characterize what's going on there
okay aaron is asking when did i first
get introduced to the internet i think i
was explaining the answer to that
um
the first place i
was actually exposed to the internet
what was the first place the first place
was
i think 1976
when i worked for
six months at the rutherford lab i was
between kind of uh leaving high school
early and going to college
um
i
worked at the reliford lab which was a
particle physics research
uh place in england
and it
was connected to the arpanet
um
and i
uh used it there
i was then
i'm trying to remember when i first saw
a list of all of the arpanet hosts
i do remember
i was
worked at argonne national lab in the
u.s in the summer of 1977
and there i definitely saw
lists of kind of the the first sort of
digest of what was out there on the on
the arpanet what were what were those
hosts and what could you do with them
and some documentation for that
then
much later
uh
i
well let's see i think um
so i was as i said i i became you know i
first had an email address in 1976.
um
i think that email address probably
wasn't accessible except through the mit
computer system that i was using through
the arpanet
i first will have had an email address
that was let me think
um
did i have an email address when i was
in
oxford
um not sure by the time
i was
um let's see i must have
by
by 1980 i certainly had an oh yes i i
definitely had an email address by 1979
because when i started working on um
on snp
uh my sort of precursor of mathematica
and wolfram language in 1979
i remember hiring a bunch of
undergraduates at caltech to work on
that and i remember communicating with
them through email so definitely by 1979
there was email at least
locally within caltech
and then as far as the web is concerned
i have to say when the web first came
into existence
um i had you know seen gopher and waste
and so on i really didn't think the web
was going to be anything terribly
special and i guess i must have first
become
really uh
aware of it i mean i became a remote ceo
in 1991 and i was using well obviously
tons and tons of email i mean i have an
archive of my email going back to that
time
um but uh
the
i started
sometime
must have been 92 or something like that
i kind of thought i was getting behind
when i realized oh the things are
happening in the web and i should start
paying attention to the web
um
i have to say that the i had known
the
folks who did the first web browsers
at university of illinois
um that must have been
in
1987 or so i remember one of the people
uh who worked on one of the first web
browsers interviewing for a job at our
company so that must have been
1988 or so we didn't hire them as it
turned out um and uh
uh whether a good or bad decision who's
to know um but any case
the uh
uh yes i think that's that's that's
roughly the
the history
um
that's there's a question from ed here
also about history of technology why did
it take so long for highly parallel
graphics cards to be applied to
scientific fields
um
well
people tried for a long time but
parallel computing is hard to do and
it's
what's happened now with gpus and so on
is that it's kind of at the low levels
of the libraries that people support gpu
computing and the application level
programmer doesn't usually do much with
the gpus it's all sort of things
happening at the level of the linear
algebra or the machine learning or
whatever else those are being done with
great effort somebody has programmed
those for gpus and the typical sort of
application level programmer or user is
just getting to take advantage of those
things rather than having to sort of
actually do the explicit programming now
there were
you know the whole history of parallel
computing goes back a long way
i mean the people started talking about
parallel computing oh by the 1950s and
1960s my favorite cellular automata were
being thought about in the 1950s and
1960s is kind of very
simple idealized models of parallel
computing the iliac computer at
university of illinois that must have
been built in the 70s and that was a
computer that had many separate parallel
processing elements as kind of the idea
like in a cellular automaton that you
would have a bunch of identical
processing elements and you would split
a problem up into all these separate
pieces and get the thing done in
parallel and there were some problems
which were much easier to see how you
would do that splitting up than others
um then
what happened by
the beginning of the 80s
much of that effort in parallel
computing had kind of fallen upon hard
times
i mean there was things
well that came out of the iliac there
was a thing called the mpp the massively
parallel processor that was a nasa
project as i recall um then there were a
number of other university projects
that were various kinds of models for
how you would do parallel computation
there were ones that involved a large
number of identical elements there are
ones that involve more like the
multi-core
computers of today where there were
processors that wouldn't necessarily be
doing the same thing and would be and
the problem
they would just be running threads in
parallel rather than sort of breaking
the problem up into lots of identical
pieces
um i got involved back in oh gosh 83 or
so
in
this company called thinking machines
corporation started by danny hillis
that was an effort to make
a sort of serious
uh very parallel sort of many identical
components uh kind of computer
danny had originally sort of conceived
of the idea of the so-called connection
machine computer
from sort of some theories of marvin
minsky's about ai
and kind of this notion that ai is all
about making connections between things
that's what intelligence is about so
this concept was let's build that in
hardware and make something which at the
at the underlying level it was a
hypercube of processors like uh two to
the 16 different processors in a
16-dimensional boolean hypercube um that
was sort of the raw architecture but on
top of that was kind of this layer where
one was able to sort of think about the
computer as allowing any processor to
connect to any other processor there
were many technical problems with doing
that which didn't really get adequately
solved um and were i think in the end
interesting theoretical problems but the
kind of the notion was ultimately it's a
massively parallel machine where
problems will be broken up into lots
pieces one of the things that happened
there was it was hard to find good
applications for that there was some
involving text searching um that
actually became um
uh that was some
uh
there were ones well that was one there
were some involving uh path finding on
graphs
there were some involving let's see what
else was there
there could have been image processing
but there wasn't
that i recall um
well and then another big application
which was one that that i kind of
developed for that machine
was using things like cellular automata
to do fluid mechanics
that was a big potential application
although um in the end
the for sort of more business management
strategy reasons that application was
not as much pushed as it could and
should have been
um and it would have changed kind of the
commercial course i think of what
happened with that machine
but it was it was tough to break
problems up into into parallel pieces
and to and to have things work well and
and even worse it was really hard to
understand how to program a massively
parallel machine because we humans are
not well set up
to think we can think in terms of
every element does the same thing but
it's much harder to think in terms of
there are all these different things
happening and they happen at different
times and so on i would say that just
recently and i've been thinking about
this problem for like 40 years just
recently as a result of our physics
project and this kind of whole
multi-computation fourth paradigm kind
of thing i think i finally may have
the the sort of raw material necessary
to actually finally finally understand
how to do the best we humans can do
at
programming a sort of distributed
parallel kind of computer but that's
been a long time coming and it's not
here yet and some of the things that
that involves are quite are things that
are pretty uh kind of sophisticated and
abstract and i don't know it's going to
be quite challenging to bring those sort
of down to earth to the point where we
can all use them routinely but so i
think one big reason is it's pretty hard
to parallel to program parallel kinds of
things there are lots of tricky issues
to think about that it's something where
we're not well set up to naturally think
in those kinds of terms
now as a practical matter
after kind of numerical linear algebra
became big in the 1960s and 1970s
people started wanting to do those kinds
of things in hardware and that was what
led to
first generation of computer graphics
processors and things like that
companies like sgi silicon graphics
incorporated i'm sure they re-themed
themselves sgi at some point was a
company that very much had
the idea of having graphics processing
capabilities built into workstation
computers so that you could have this
desktop computer that could do all this
fancy 3d rotation
and 3d rendering and so on that's where
um the the gl we're now opengl graphics
language came from and that was there
were a number of competing companies at
that time but sgi was probably the one
that that uh went the furthest um but
that was something again where somebody
programmed the low-level kind of
microcode level uh kind of
handling of the whole graphics processor
and so on and the application layer is
just like let's send it some geometry
and then it will render it on the screen
the idea of actually programming
directly with that stuff has been very
difficult it's still difficult
it's still something where mostly people
are just dealing with layers on top of
all of that kind of thing
and and certainly what we've done in
wolfram language for example in
supporting things like neural nets and
so on is is we've we've provided a bunch
of convenient boxes where the actual
details of how that really works at the
gpu level is is something you know we've
worked on or we use libraries that do it
and so on and it's not something that is
exposed to the the typical end user so i
think this is a thing where the end of
that story is not told yet
i i actually think that i have something
to contribute to that um in terms of
this sort of new approach to thinking
about distributed computing and
programming distributed systems and
that's uh something to look forward to
for 2022 i hope
all right i shouldn't go on too much
longer here but um uh
okay there's a another
um
[Music]
it's a question from
william uh no there's a question here
sorry from wolf
asking um
uh mentioning that i at one point
mentioned that i knew julia robinson
and um
uh
for more comments about that okay so a
little bit of history
so
the field of mathematical logic
was something that
really got serious in the late 1800s
uh
gottlob frago was a was an early
contributor
um then
it um it really got a big boost around
19 well
1900 david hilbert was was sort of
talking about it a bunch and thinking
about how one would sort of formulate
mathematics and logical terms and then
it got a big boost 1910 with with uh
whitehead and russell publishing their
big three volume principia mathematica
book trying to kind of show how all of
mathematics could be derived from logic
and
they developed this kind of fairly rich
and very technical and rather
non-mathematical looking
field of mathematical logic
deeply steeped in formalism but of a
very different kind from traditional
mathematics
um it got kind of a bit of a a side
swipe with goodell's theorem in 1931
of some sort of early hopes of we'll
just be able to make all of mathematics
mechanical
looking like that wasn't going to happen
but still they developed this field of
mathematical logic
and one of the things that came out of
girl's theorem was the idea of
undecidability the idea that there are
questions where there is no finite
computation which can guarantee to
answer the question and
from that came
a number of different kinds of problems
where people could say well in this
thing that looks a little bit more like
ordinary mathematics
is there something undecidable in that
question
and so there are a number of problems
about of of undecidability that were
being discovered in the 1940s 1950s
1960s and so on
uh one of those uh was worked on by a
chap called raphael robinson
um uh who was a a mathematician at
berkeley not quite sure what his early
mathematical work was
but um uh he worked on uh tilings and
the question of if you're given a set of
tiles like a set of puzzle pieces and
you're asked can you use an infinite
number of copies of each of these uh
puzzle pieces to tile an infinite plane
can you answer that question in general
clearly if you're given hexagons you can
type regular hexagons you can tile the
plane if you're given regular octagons
you can't tell the plane but what if
you're given a couple of weird shapes
can you tile the plane with those or not
well raphael robinson came up with a set
of shapes i think oh i know six or seven
of them maybe
where which have all kinds of strange
notches and so on where they have the
feature that the class of shapes of this
type
in general
you can't answer that question of
whether you can tile the plane or not
you might be able to tile for a trillion
sort of tiles and then it might get
stuck you never can know in general it's
an undecidable problem so that was a
result due to raphael robinson
uh julia robinson
uh became um
was was rafael robinson's wife
and um she
was a very strong mathematician
who um uh
for
reasons of the um uh even though
uc berkeley
california might today seem like it's at
the vanguard or might like to think of
itself as the vanguard of kind of uh
equality of everything julia robinson
for a long time was unhirable by the
university of california um uh because
because she was a woman and a sort of a
strange setup but any case she she that
eventually um uh got resolved but she
was working on um all sorts of uh all
sorts of mathematics there was quite a
strong group of mathematical logic at uc
berkeley julia robinson worked on a
specific problem this is in the 1960s
um
with on um
to do with
hilbert's 10th problem so hilbert in
1900 have proposed these 23 mathematical
problems the tenth problem was
if you were given a different sign
equation an equation involving variables
that have to be integers
is it the case
that
you can determine from any if you're
given a different time equation can you
tell by looking at the differential
equation in a sense whether the whether
the equation has any solutions or not
and it turned out that it became
increasingly suspected that that
question was undecidable that if you
look to the class of defense and
equations that there will be no upper
bound on how long you might have to
grind to compute to figure out whether
whether an equation had solutions or not
and uh julia robinson
actually proved that hilbert's tenth
problem was undecidable for a class of
of different time equations that
involved exponentials and so on and that
was a big
development that was done with martin
davis
um who's still alive and actually was
part of a
big discussion that we did about
the um about post systems a number of
months ago and about emerald post
um
very case the um julia robinson and and
martin davis
um
were responsible for proving that
this um
uh that these exponential diaphantine
equations uh
made hilbert's tenth problem the version
of it for exponential equations
undecidable
subsequently i think it was 1968 a chap
called yuri matisevic
young russian mathematician well
actually i noticed i just got email from
yesterday about about diaphanton
equations of all things um that uh um
uh
was it was a time when sort of that was
at a time when when the cold war was
sort of going on and sort of what was
happening in the soviet union was very
separate from what was happening in the
us
and apparently it was before my time but
but um apparently it was sort of a big
dramatic thing when it was announced
that this young
sort of soviet mathematician had proved
that you didn't need to have exponential
different equations you could encode the
exponentials in terms of ordinary
polynomial different time equations and
so the originally stated hilbert's tenth
problem was undecidable that was a big
dramatic thing and yuri maticevic kind
of put the put the put the cherry on the
top of that particular cake or something
that had been uh uh worked on by by
julie robinson and martin davis
well i think i i must have met julie
robinson because when the macarthur
foundation started giving out its its uh
uh fellowships back in 1981
um
they were kind enough to give me one of
their their first batch of those things
and probably the most interesting thing
the macarthur foundation did was every
18 months or so they would have a
get-together of all of the um
macarthur fellows they would invite all
of them only a subset will come but that
was a fascinating group of people i mean
in those days the idea of kind of a
mixer conference that had uh people from
all sorts of different fields
was something quite unknown i mean in in
today's world you know from from ted
onwards to to endless other kinds of
conferences the idea of just sort of
bringing together people who might find
each other interesting from lots of
different fields is quite a known thing
but in those days it absolutely was not
and and for me it was uh
very interesting and i met many people
who i still in touch with to this day
um from uh at those early macarthur
get-togethers and julia robinson
together with rafael robinson was one of
the people who who came to those um i
remember
oh lots of people i remember barbara
mcclintock who was a big genetics person
remember meeting her there and people
who are still around like cormac
mccarthy are a um novelist or people
like howard gardner who's an education
psychology type person these are people
who are still around i'm still very much
in touch with um and uh and many other
people
who
have long since passed away were were at
those early conferences but that was
some um i i have to say when i uh when i
i you know meeting julia and rafael
robinson the um
uh
they were just very pleasant older
people and um
very uh
uh i
you know at the time i was sort of uh
you know i sort of divide history into
before the web and after the web
and
after the web
you know if i had met
julie robinson now i would have
immediately looked her up on the web and
i would have found oh she worked on all
this stuff about undecidability i'm
really interested in undecidability this
is what i should talk to her about but
before the web i didn't know any of that
stuff
and so
i don't think i i'm trying to remember
if i ever talk to
raphael robinson about tilings because
i've been pretty interested in tilings
for a really long time and i'm not sure
that i ever did
and i'm not i think
i must have known hmm when did i know
that uh
yeah i must have known about
i certainly knew of robinson tilings
by
uh the kind of time
within a few years of when i must have
been interacting with with those those
two um but
i'm not even sure i made the connection
that you know robinson robinson you know
i
and this is this is you know the world
of doing these things before the web so
i don't think i have any particularly uh
insightful
stories to tell
um
i'm trying to remember
gosh
i'm um
i have a definite image of of um
uh at least one time
when i
ran into
those two um
but uh
i'm not recalling anything particularly
notable to report about that
um
let's see maybe one more question and
then i should
wrap up for today
oh boy people asking about things i
don't know about
um
it's a question from dylan about
heidegger
uh ask me again in a month or two i'm
i'm i'm on a a big effort to really
understand more about the history of
philosophy
but i don't think i can comment on that
usefully now
um
let's see
um
at asks how does self-organizing
order emerge in physics and biology are
they analogous
can the universe be said to be in the
business of self-organization
well
okay this is a topic i got interested in
the late 1970s and
been an interest in it for a long time
but at some level the topic is kind of
there's a trivial version of the topic
and the trivial version is this
sometimes things will start very random
and then
they'll be sort of attracted to some
state that isn't so random so for
example let's say you have a ball
rolling around on some landscape and
there's it rolls around and it can go in
all kinds of different places and all
kinds of different paths and there's a
kind of a lowest point on the landscape
and the ball just always eventually
rolls down to that lowest point that's
kind of the attractor on the landscape
and so you might say there's all this
complicated stuff going on the bulls
going all these different places and it
looks kind of random and and so on but
in the end it's going to organize itself
into the ball is down at the lowest
point on the landscape
and there are many analogous versions to
that
there are many things where you can
start with chemical processes and and
there'll be there'll be something where
the thing looks very random and then
it'll organize itself to just be in
periodic waves or it'll organize itself
to make sort of certain kinds of spiral
patterns or whatever else
these are things which these kinds of
attractors are happening just because
there are many initial states that the
system can be in but only a much smaller
number of final states like the ball
rolling around on the landscape and that
phenomenon of of evolution towards
attractors
is something that is quite generic it's
something whenever you have a system
where in a sense information is lost
whenever there's sort of more possible
initial conditions than there are final
conditions that will be what happens so
quite a lot of what people used to call
self-organization in the 1970s and so on
is really just that phenomenon and that
phenomenon is in a sense a
straightforward formal and mathematical
phenomenon um it can it can show up in
more and more elaborate ways i was very
excited when i first saw sort of a
sophisticated version of that phenomenon
in cellular automata where the things
that you are attracted to can themselves
be very complicated now the next
question is
how can when when thing when complicated
things come out how do they get made and
that's the thing i've been very long
interested in it's kind of like you've
got some procedure some program for
making something does it always make
something simple or can it make
something complicated and the big
discovery that sort of launched my whole
new kind of science thing and so on was
the discovery that you could have very
simple rules that would produce very
complicated behavior
now whether you call that behavior
organized or self-organized or whatever
i'm not sure
but the main point is that even from a
very simple rule you can make very
complicated behavior you can kind of
combine these phenomena you can say you
start from random stuff it kind of gets
attracted down to something and then
that thing itself can produce very
complicated behavior but that's a
separate phenomenon the phenomenon by
which one can make very complicated
behavior even from very simple rules is
something different from the phenomenon
of attracting from randomness down to a
smaller number of states that phenomenon
of being able to go from simple rules to
elaborate complicated behavior core
phenomenon they you know
my favorite sort of discovery in the in
the particularly dramatic version of it
is in my rule 30 cellular automaton but
the phenomenon is one that now that one
has that kind of paradigm one can look
back and see kind of earlier versions of
it in things like i don't know the
distribution of prime numbers the digits
of pi these are all things described by
fairly simple programs yet once
generated they look complicated and
random is that what the universe is
doing absolutely
at some level at least the you know i'm
i'm really quite certain that the
universe says as we see it is a story of
going from essentially what one might
describe of as simple rules
to sort of all the richness of what we
actually see in the physical universe
and so in a sense that's what the
universe is doing but self-organization
well sometimes that means going from
something random to something simpler
and i'm not sure that's that's what the
universe well there's some aspects of
what the universe has done um that might
be a bit like that but i tend to think
that the much stronger phenomenon is
this phenomenon that's all wrapped up
with computational irreducibility of
going from simple rules to complicated
behavior
i think that um
uh when we look at physics and biology
uh biology
i think makes a lot of use of this
simple rules complicated behavior um we
see that at very sort of straightforward
levels in like pigmentation patterns
growth patterns in biology but i'm sure
that it's something that gets made use
of at many layers in biology i would say
that one of the things that has been
hard to understand in biology is
biological evolution is a kind of a
gradual change kind of thing and this
essentially computational phenomenon of
making complicated stuff from very
simple rules is something that doesn't
particularly we don't really know how to
mesh that particularly well
with the kind of the gradual change kind
of approach that biological evolution
seems to make and so that that remains
sort of a core fundamental question of
biological evolution how to think about
that how to think about sort of the the
making of more and more complex species
um and uh if indeed there are more and
more complex i mean as you know as as
viruses start to take over the world so
to speak they're not that's not a
complex organism relative to to us
humans and things like that and it's not
clear that the the winner in the
struggle for life so to speak is always
the more complex organism
but sort of there's this whole question
of of what
uh what drives kind of all of the what
drives sort of any
complexity in biology i think one sort
of point of view
is that uh there's always a better
program that it's a feature of sort of a
computational process that if you have a
particular
uh that that
you know if you have a sufficiently
general objective there will always be a
better program at achieving that
objective
and that's similar to the
it's it's related to the phenomenon of
undecidability and phenomena of
computational irreducibility there'll
always be if you have programs competing
with each other in some measure of
competition there'll always be a better
program that can be made
you'll never sort of run out of that
frontier and perhaps that's part of what
the story of biology is i don't think
that particular thing is so much the
story of physics
and i think that the um the question of
of how
the relationship between physics and
biology interesting one i mean i have to
say i have long been of the general
belief that the phenomenon of life
is at its core very much related to
computational irreducibility my
principle of computational equivalence
things like this that it's essentially
just a phenomenon of the ability to do
sophisticated computation i've actually
been wondering recently whether that's
really all one can say
i mean it's always a question when we
discover that thing
on on
you know europa or something and um we
say is this alive or is it not alive it
doesn't have rna it's not like life on
earth but does it have characteristics
that make us think we should tag this as
being alive
what should we really be looking for
it's been tough to know and i've thought
that there really isn't probably a kind
of bright line distinction between the
merely computational and the alive so to
speak
other than things that are specific to
life on earth like having rna and things
like this and so i i think
i i'm beginning to think that maybe
there is something that one can identify
that is more sort of specific about
life
than that and i don't know what the
you know people have said throughout
history that that things that were hard
to make machines do
or other kinds of um apparently just
purely physical systems do but what was
important about life like being able to
move itself that was a in antiquity that
was a common definition
um then it was like being able to
achieve certain chemical
uh changes or being able to achieve
certain thermodynamic changes or being
able to reproduce itself these are all
things which gradually over time we
found systems that very much don't have
all of the machinery of life but still
are able to do those things and so we
kind of have to think differently about
what is the essential phenomenon that we
identify as life
and i i have this sort of slight
suspicion that there may be some
something
to do with kind of the identification of
individuals and things like this and the
the sort of the fact that life involves
sort of copying a lot of mechanism but
not completely and so on
that there may be something related to
that that one can identify as being
sort of the essential feature of what it
means to be a living system rather than
just a computational and complicated
system i mean i part of what's inspired
this idea is that i had long sort of
thought that consciousness was another
one of these things that was best
just sort of thought of as being lumped
in with generic computation but i
realized from our physics project that
there's actually more to consciousness
in addition to being sort of a bounded
computational
uh
computational but bounded computation
another important thing seems to be this
notion of persistence this notion that
that to be conscious is to experience
things in a definite thread of
experience that's our definition of
consciousness i mean perhaps to the
aliens they might use that word so to
speak to describe their experience which
might not involve that at all it might
involve a multi-threaded you know
multi-branched kind of experience of
time but for us
our experience of time is very much this
experience of there is a single thread
of experience
that we have
and and that's related and that we have
some persistence that we even though we
might at different moments be made from
different atoms of space
it's still the same us at least as far
as we're concerned and the same thread
of experience that we go through and and
we can therefore have belief
in phenomena like causality because we
have this idea that we are constant and
so we can look at the causes of other
things that way if we were saying we are
remade at every moment and we don't
connect one moment with another moment
then sort of the notion of causality is
lost
and this is related for example for us
one of the other important features of
us is the idea of pure motion the idea
that things that you can have things
that move around in space without
changing that you can take an object and
even though it's made of different atoms
of space where you move it to a
different place it's still the same
thing and that's also important to us as
consciousnesses that we perceive
ourselves to be sort of the same thing
even though we're kind of even though we
might move around in space and be made
of different atoms of space
so this idea of sort of maintaining
integrity
through space and time is something that
seems important to the idea of
consciousness and i rather suspect that
there may be a definition of life
that is a better and tighter definition
than just the merely computational and
that somehow relates to some kind of
identification of integrity of the thing
uh with respect to its kind of existence
through a certain amount of time and so
on
i don't yet know how this works out it's
something that that
i'd like to think about
all right we should wrap up here uh for
now
and um
so
uh thanks for joining us
and um
happy new year
and see you another time